the winners and new champions of Dancing
with the Stars are Bobby and Sharda you
guys first of all this is absolutely
incredible you both looked a little bit
shocked though I think you wanted to say
insane I think you were gonna go with
incredible that's what I think it was
about to happen yeah why we were shocked
I mean you have to think about it we
started the show I'd never danced before
she got stuck with someone
she's an athletes and people that are
like super didn't and then she gets
stuck she's in Nick Carter Antonio Brown
and then all of a sudden she gets Gumby
and so she's like yeah it's like whoa
and we win and you know one I had to
trust her a lot and I did and it took a
second but I did and she also had to
trust me which is a weird thing because
I would say stuff like hey I know you
think I'm nuts but trust me on this one
like I like so we've it took us a second
because she got mad at me when I lost
and then what we've lost in our final
act that that to me is kind of the the
the metaphor of our whole journey
together is that we kind of didn't know
we're both Type A personalities you go
uh-huh and then all the sudden you start
to see that person to be successful at
something you go home for me I'm happy
for me I'm happy for my people that
helped us I'm happy for her people they
helped us but mostly I'm happy for her
like I'm the most happy for freaking
Sharma because she deserved this it is
your first mirror ball I feel like
Entertainment Tonight started the
hashtag justice for Sharna years ago
might I ask if you feel like this has
been justice for Sharna oh yeah in more
ways than I could even count or imagine
this is probably the sweetest win that I
could have had over seven seasons the
journey that we had together what we
represented and to hold a mirror ball at
the end of that I mean it's just it's
the hardest work you had to do to
possible yeah but YouTube the hardest
worker she had to do I
she's hot all right I am goofy I mean I
my elbows and knees don't go the right
directions like she made him go the
right directions most of the time but
but and when they didn't shoot they were
supposed to ask you I mean you want to
disable your comments on social media
what do you have to say to those critics
now nothing nothing
listen it I turned it off not because it
was hurting me but because my people are
fighting with them and I understand what
that happen I try to take any sort of
negativity out of my space because once
it's in me and around me then it affects
me so I just eliminated it I wasn't
angry you know people say things all the
time they're right and then their
absolute rights to have their opinion
but I try to keep you good people around
me because it makes me a better person
my whole career is being surrounded by
great people and this is another example
of that like I'm not that good at this
but she's fantastic at this and together
we made it work where are you guys gonna
keep these mirror balls I think I'm
probably just gonna hold it for quite a
while like I don't have anything around
yeah it's really heavy my arms are gonna
be here like right I'm gonna drop it I'm
scared I think for a while yeah like the
front scene in your car absolutely seat
belt and everything where are you gonna
keep your bed I'm gonna sleep with every
night I probably probably get it its own
Bumble profile yeah yeah listen we're
best buds now so I'm looking out for him
too yeah are you gonna name him
not yeah I don't know we haven't really
got to know each other yes oh it's hard
to name something before you really know
the personality so yeah yeah so I don't
know we're so excited we don't even know
how excited we are yet because this just
happened one shot still sinking in
we don't even understand what our
feelings are right now thank you before
I let you guys go what are you gonna
miss most about each other during this
process
ographers I'm gonna miss getting pushed
to the point where I'm super
uncomfortable and then it work it ends
up working because what would happen is
you would learn a new we have to learn a
new dance then you go in on Tuesday and
it is it's all it's an awful day because
you're it's like learning a new language
every week like you know how to speak
but you don't know the new language and
the first three four five weeks I hate
those days because I feel so foolish but
then I started to understand the beauty
in that and then it always worked out in
the end and I trusted it more because I
trusted her more and if anything that's
what I'm gonna miss and that I knew that
I had a sidekick and a leader that was
gonna put me in the right place even
though I felt awkward terrible and I was
doing everything wrong I'm gonna miss
all of that I'm gonna miss watching
Bobby grow from the beginning of the
week to the end of the week and then
seeing his performance come out on
Monday but I think mostly I'm gonna miss
our human type when we get to just hang
out and be be people with each other
that's not that aren't dancing I'm not
yelling at him I think five six seven
eight and and getting to know him and
watching him open up and be vulnerable
not just to me but to everybody watching
him do something that he's uncomfortable
doing and I you know he's inspired the
people but he's also inspired me so I
can't believe that I cannot believe we
won thank you to everybody who voted for
us take it as Sharna I should just take
my shoes off and leave a middle floor
walk and go home and never come back
just sign your other pair judges did
sign my other one oh how cool that's
gonna be such a treasured thing to me
like they sign my black Jordan I was
wearing out here and I know what I
thought it was crazy that was the only
time I was getting to do that let's just
take my shoe and get him to sign it so
it was awesome I'm tired and happy and
hungry and happy first meal gonna be
whatever they have back there in the
back yeah
[Applause]
you